foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
all right
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
all right
[Applause]
[Music]
hey folks welcome to the Dark Horse
podcast live stream number 181 I am Dr
Brett Weinstein this is Dr Heather Hein
it is July 5th 2023. it is yeah it is uh
it's the day after Independence Day
I must say independence day has become a
rather poignant event for those of us
who are concerned about this marvelous
nation of ours yeah I feel more
explicitly patriotic than I recall
feeling before
yeah it's interesting I don't I don't
feel a difference in the patriotism but
I feel a difference in the urgency which
maybe that's a distinction without a
difference no no I get it I think I
think I understand I think um
I think even though we did a lot of
international traveling early in our 20s
and our 30s and it was in those travels
that I came to understand how much value
there was in our home country and and
how much we had going on even while
there were flaws uh I think that in
combination with what you were
identifying as an urgency a sense of wow
this may actually this may actually be
at serious risk due to many people's
failure to recognize what it is that we
have has has caused it to feel at this
point like it's um
like we all need to find our patriotism
honestly yeah yeah I've been having many
conversations with people that we know
and I think this is a a Dawning
Collective realization about about the
moment we live in
and I think about the
fact that the Jeopardy is even it's well
beyond the Republic it's obviously a
global phenomenon it is obviously a
political Jeopardy in the sense that
authoritarianism seems to be taking root
lots of regressive belief structures
seem to be returning with a Vengeance
and
I think also across the board people are
also recognizing that the the structures
that Drive the world biotically are not
healthy yeah there's there's no shortage
of Jeopardy there is no charge of
Jeopardy yes unfortunately that is true
um okay let's get to uh just top of the
air Logistics stuff before before
launching in uh this is live stream 181
as you said second half of a twin Prime
with 179
yeah now you can yeah twin Prime are
primes that are only one digit apart uh
they have only one digit between them
they only have one integer one sorry
I should tell the people at home you
know perhaps those who are just
listening and therefore cannot see that
I am fighting seasonal allergies and I'm
uh let's say I'm fighting valiantly but
I am not winning no
now you have you have your moments of uh
you you win occasional battles as far as
I can tell no I do I win some battles I
win some battles and ultimately I will
uh I Will Survive to sneeze another day
but
um but it ain't pretty sometimes so yeah
so yeah that's it's sort of uh
preemptive apology for the sniffles and
the uh yeah yes and uh you know it's
possible again people who are just
listening will never detect it because
of my uh my amazing levels of
professionalism but people who are
watching could see a kind of a snot a
palooza I I'm not guaranteeing that
won't happen I am okay good wow
because we have a producer here who will
cut to
cut the black Oh I thought you were
implying you had some sort of a big
clothes pin over there you were gonna
Rush In And prevent such a thing okay so
if you're watching on YouTube please
consider joining us on Rumble and
subscribing to our Channel there we've
got another live stream uh this coming
Saturday on July 8th and then no more
until Wednesday July 19th we've got some
uh some things that various people have
to do and then we're going to be coming
to you regularly on Wednesdays uh at 11
30 a.m uh Pacific from from then on so
we're moving our live stream schedules
to Wednesdays 11 30 a.m with the
exception that this coming Saturday will
be our last regular Saturday podcast and
we have chat live on Rumble today as
we've been doing since we moved to
rumble a little while back but we're
going to go on chat Hiatus for two weeks
and then we'll return on July 19th with
no chat we're gonna stop chat and we are
going to instead encourage locals only
live conversation what we're going to
call it a watch party watch party yeah
so we have not we locals is there like
you can go there we have not yet set up
like what the you know what what the
amounts will be so at the moment you can
go and there are people there having
good conversations but we're going to
basically do a uh see see if we can help
improve uh what we are hearing is uh a a
not as fabulous level of conversation as
some people in the chat would hope for
by moving it into into local so one last
live chat today
um and today's time we're not going to
do a q a today but we will on Saturday
today's topics include we're going to
talk a little bit more about freedoms in
higher ed Brett is going to present a
thought experiment and we're also going
to talk about some research and
Reporting on cancer rates that vary by
sex
we have
some new merch psyop until proven
otherwise check it out at
darkhorsestore.org and we're going to
tell you about all the rest Natural
Selections patreons all that at the end
but what we will do before launching
into the main podcast is as usual uh
present to you our sponsors all of whom
we um
truly and
um and thoughtfully do vouch for we have
three of them as usual at the top of the
hour here we go our first sponsor this
week is new to us it's Hillsdale College
if you are a few years or decades out of
school and wondering what you learned
and what was the point not alone
maybe you wish you'd taken more time to
study topics it would be more meaningful
to you or some you know something
lasting and profound if so you're also
not alone and it's not too late
since 1844 that's 1844 Hillsdale College
has been providing an education that
focuses on freedom and character because
they believe that a virtuous citizen is
the best defense for Liberty that's why
they've taken some of the core classes
they teach on campus and made them
available for free online for anyone who
wants to learn that's right for free
time and Technology have changed a lot
of things but they have not changed
basic fundamental truths about the world
in our place in it
I spent some time on their site this
week looking at some of their online
courses and they really look fantastic
there are several in the Constitution
Congress and the presidency and the
Supreme Court they're great books
courses as well as courses focusing on
the works of C.S Lewis I'm Mark Twain
Shakespeare Jane Austen more excuse me
there's history from ancient
Christianity to the rise and fall the
Roman Republic the second world war and
even classes on math and logic from
Euclid to Modern geometry and one on the
great principles of chemistry over three
million people have taken Hillsdale
College online course you could be next
there are 39 free courses to choose from
they're easy to follow self-paced so you
can start wherever you want
whenever you want in fact you can start
right now it's everything you need all
in one place with no long-term
commitment learn when and where you want
enjoy now nope enroll now in hillsdale's
not for credit online courses program
it's free it's fun and it will change
the way you understand our country
the world and your place in it go right
now to hillsdale.edu Darkhorse to enroll
there's no cost it's easy to get started
that's hillsdale.edu Darkhorse to
register once again
hillsdale-h-i-l-l-s-d-a-l-e dot edu
Darkhorse
fantastic very excited to have them as a
sponsor yes so am I very much so
our second sponsor this week is mud
water one of our favorites mud water
makes a fantastic drink it's spicy and
delicious and chock full of adaptogenic
mushrooms and ayurvedic herbs with 1 7
the caffeine is a cup of coffee you get
energy without the anxiety Jitters your
crash of coffee it can be thought of as
a coffee alternative but it's way more
than that if you like the routine of
making and drinking a cup of warmth in
the morning but don't drink coffee or
trying to cut down try mud water if
you're looking for a different way to
kick off your day a delicious warming
and handsome way that isn't just a
caffeine Rush try mud water each
ingredient was added with intention it
has cacao and chai for just a hint of
caffeine lion's mane mushrooms to
support Focus cordyceps to help support
physical performance chaga and reishi to
support your immune system and cinnamon
which is a potent antioxidant and many
more ingredients besides mud water also
makes a non-dairy creamer out of coconut
milk and MCT and a sweetener out of
coconut palm sugar and lucuma which is
the fruit of an Andean tree which was
used by the Inca to add if you prefer
those options
or you can mix and match add a bit of
their coconut milk and MCT creamer with
some honey from bees real bees or use
mud Waters lucuma and coconut palm sugar
sweetener and skip the bees entirely if
you don't like bees
mud water's flavor is warm and spicy
with a hint of chocolate my favorite
plus Masala chai which includes Ginger
and cardamom nutmeg and cloves it's also
delicious blended into a smoothie I
recommend trying it with banana and Ice
milk or milk like substance mint and
cacao nibs fantastic
mud water's flavor is warm and spicy
with a hint of chocolate now I already
read that paragraph didn't I wow
wow yep it's like we've been hurdled
backwards in time yes by like 12 seconds
not very far better any any regression
in time is significant yeah it's it's
groundhog minute
not a thing but okay mud water is 100
USDA organic non-GMO gluten-free vegan
and kosher certified and it allows you
to build a morning ritual to promote
sustained energy without the crash to
get 15 off go to mudwater.com
Dark Horse pod to support the show use
code Dark Horse pod that's Dark Horse
pod pod for 15 off and oh let me just
spell it mud water is
m-u-d-w-t-r so to get 15 off go to
mudwtr.com darkhorsepod to support the
show
all right our third sponsor this week is
grass pollen
no
and our final sponsor this week is Vivo
Barefoot hypoallergenic shoes made for
feet now I don't actually know that
they're hypoallergenic but I think I've
never given you this I wear them all
year and I only sneeze during grass
pollen season so chances are very very
low
if they're not hypoallergenic they're
very close to it shoes made for feet is
what I was getting at man I'm so sorry
uh it wasn't my fault
I didn't invent the monocots no you
didn't no you didn't and thank you for
not yeah they were around long before I
was yes all right back to the topic at
hand Vivo was one of our very first
sponsors and they remain one of our
favorites everyone should try these
shoes most shoes are made for someone's
idea of feet not vivos vivos are made by
people with feet who know how to use
them and word is spreading people often
approach us because of the vivos we are
wearing saying that they've heard that
they're very good
and they are they're every bit as good
as you have heard here at Darkhorse we
love these shoes they are Beyond
comfortable the tactile feedback from
the surfaces you're walking on is
amazing and they cause no pain at all
because there are no pressure points
forcing your feet into odd positions
they are fantastic
our feet are the product of millions of
years of evolution humans evolve to walk
move and run Barefoot modern shoes that
are overly cushioned and strangely
shaped have negatively impacted foot
function and are contributing to a
Health crisis
people move less than they might in part
because their shoes make their feet hurt
enter Vivo Barefoot Vivo barefoot shoes
are designed wide to provide natural
stability thin to enable you to feel
more and flexible to help you build your
natural strength from the ground up but
strength increases by 60 in a matter of
months just by walking around in them
Vivo Barefoot has a great range of
Footwear for kids and adults and for
every activity from hiking to training
and everyday wear they're also a
certified B Corp that is pioneering
regenerative business principles and
their Footwear is produced using
sustainably sourced natural and recycled
materials with the aim to protect the
natural world so you can run wild upon
it go to vivobarefoot.com and use the
code Darkhorse 15 to get an exclusive 15
off
additionally all new customers get a 100
day free trial so you can see if you
love them as much as we do that's Vivo
b-a-r-e-f-o-o-t.com and use the chord
code darkhorse15 at checkout point of
order yes
yes do they make shoes for hooved
animals
I do not believe those Super Shoes
horseshoes or anything like that I think
Horseshoes and zebra shoes are the same
shoes they just rebranded for a
different Market absolutely probably at
a increase of price for the zebras
or a decrease in price no I'm thinking
higher I guess there are fewer zebras so
the cost per unit sure okay higher price
for the zebra shoes but I don't think so
also just fancier fancier animals in
general may be more concerned about
their their looks just like the same
product is rebranded for women and the
price goes up I expect that zebra shoes
are more expensive than horseshoes but I
do wonder if Evo makes sleeper shoes see
here's the thing yep it's not just the
rebranding for women it's the pH
balancing
so there's work involved it's it's not
for nothing
oh man
what a planet oh gosh I you know I don't
know if if uh Millennials or or gen Z's
will get like this is such a Gen X
targeted deodorant commercial right this
is secret yes pH branded pH balance it
would have been more accurate yeah
exactly yeah
oh good lord
um not to say that there aren't sweat
differences between men and women but
for Fox sake yeah exactly ffs yeah all
right
okay let's start um I have a correction
to make from last time which um then I
would I hope that we can just talk a
little bit about
um a little bit more than I discovered
so we talked extensively last time about
the Supreme Court's recent ruling that
universities cannot use race as a factor
in Admissions and I mentioned I'm not
sure I mentioned by name but I mentioned
that in 1957 in Sweezy versus New
Hampshire a ruling
uh of the Supreme Court then in a
concurring opinion uh justice Felix
Frankfurter enumerated the four
essential freedoms of University
and I've now gone back and it was
actually surprisingly difficult to find
his complete opinion there he's he's
quoted a lot of places
um but it's it's excerpted and I've now
got the complete opinion and it turns
out he didn't say that
um and so one of the one of the lessons
here is even when you are you know
quoting something out of for instance
the Supreme Court itself uh you need to
go back and find your original sources
or you know lay the trail so that it's
clear like where the era may have
happened he does those words do show up
in his opinion but he is quoting someone
else
uh he himself is quoting a statement
from a conference of senior Scholars at
the University of Cape Town and if it
virus around I don't know don't speak
Afrikaans I don't know I was compelled
yeah okay both in South Africa um so
these aren't his words but theirs and I
want to share
um what the whole thing that he's
actually quoting here uh in this opinion
so Zach you can go ahead and share my
screen here if you like so this is again
a concurring opinion by Justice
Frankfurter in Sweezy versus New Zealand
New Hampshire in 1957. and he's quoting
from this conference of Scholars uh at
open universities in South Africa in a
university knowledge is its own end not
merely a means to an end a university
ceases to be true to its own nature if
it becomes the tool of church or state
or any sectional interest a university
is characterized by the spirit of free
inquiry it's ideal being the ideal of
Socrates to follow the argument where it
leads this implies the right to examine
question modify or reject traditional
ideas and beliefs Dogma at hypothesis
are incompatible and the concept of an
immutable Doctrine is repugnant to the
spirit of a university the concern of
its Scholars is not merely to add and
revise facts in relation to an accepted
framework but to be ever examining and
modifying the framework itself
freedom to reason and freedom for
disputation on the basis of observation
and experiment are the necessary
conditions for the advancement of
scientific knowledge
a sense of freedom is also necessary for
Creative work in the Arts which equally
with scientific research is the concern
of the University
it is the business of a university to
provide that atmosphere which is most
conducive to speculation experiment and
creation it is an atmosphere in which
there prevailed the four essential
freedoms of a university to determine
for itself on academic grounds who may
teach what may be taught how it shall be
taught and who may be admitted to study
and again that's Justice Frankfurter in
1957 quoting the open universities in
South Africa
stunning stunningly
it's not prescient exactly it's just
it's it's stunningly on point yes well
articulated and
demonstrates how far we are falling in
our understanding of what it is that
universities are for what it is that
science is what it is that we are
supposedly doing and supposed to be
doing at all the levels in the
University from you know from
undergraduates through you know senior
PhD researchers
yeah in fact the the line in there that
hits the hardest for me uh I'll be
interested if it struck you the same way
is
approximately dogma and hypothesis are
incompatible yes and this is the one
line repudiation of the entire Mania
over uh misinformation follow the
science all of this and it's what we
have been uh trying to articulate
throughout is that in fact one
has to be able to explore
without guard rails including many ideas
that will turn out to be incorrect In
order to find things that we do not yet
know to be true that we will ultimately
understand to be true and for the
universities to have participated not
just stood back but participated in
trying to regulate thought over what was
believed to be true in a emergency right
this was declared an emergency that
means it's emergent that means nobody's
an expert it's all new
etymology of the two words yeah yeah I
mean it's it's literally right there
they're telling you this is a realm in
which nobody is expert which means that
we are going to have to try out a whole
group of ideas most of which will turn
out to be false and then some of them
will be stubbornly robust and refuse to
be falsified and we will ultimately
recognize that those are the true ones
who the hell were these people telling
their own employees and the rest of the
world what they were required to think
right yeah no I I agree with you it's
that long Dogma a hypothesis are
incompatible
and I think in part it reveals well that
it is that is simply true and what we
saw among so many who claim to be people
of Science and people of medicine which
needs to be informed scientifically even
if it is understood to be a practical
application of scientific understanding
as opposed to a science and of itself
what we saw revealed was something that
we'd been seeing
since we started out in Academia which
is that unfortunately many people even
who are actively getting or have already
gotten credentialed in science don't
appear to understand what it is that
that means and so you will see people
claiming it's not about the pursuit of
Truth really well then what it is it
about oh hypothesis doesn't matter
seriously what does them and so we have
the rise of Insidious
seemingly obvious phrases like data
driven data-driven science no it's not
it's not how it is and yet you know from
well well back before we had in kind of
a public stage we were seeing this at at
universities that we were affiliated
with
um claims that to do science you needed
to be data driven that suggests that the
data come first the data never come
first the data are a test of a
hypothesis which means the data come
first you have not tested a hypothesis
in which case they're not data in
support of any scientific conclusion
yeah they're observations
right so um just a few more words for
Frankfort and these are these are
actually his words in this
um
in this concurring opinion from 1957 you
can show my screen if you like here's
Zach I've just got a few little sections
here he says
progress in the Natural Sciences is not
remotely confined to findings made in
the laboratory
insights into the mysteries of nature
are born of hypothesis and speculation
for society's good if understanding be
an essential need of society inquiries
into these problems speculations about
them stimulation and others of
reflection upon them must be left as
unfettered as possible political power
must abstain from intrusion to this
activity of Freedom pursued in the
interest of wise government and the
people's well-being except for reasons
that are exigent and obviously
compelling
one more this means the exclusion of
governmental intervention in the
intellectual life of a university it
matters little whether such intervention
occurs avowidly or through action that
inevitably tends to check the order and
fearlessness of Scholars qualities at
once so fragile and so indispensable for
Fruitful academic labor
so here we have Frankfurt arguing for
order interesting word here the order
and fearlessness of Scholars once again
qualities at once so fragile and so
indispensable for Fruitful academic
labor and of course
that is partly what tenure is supposed
to provide right this is this is this is
the point of tenure tenure has problems
for sure and there I I have I have heard
and I have I have found myself on the
side of arguments on both sides of the
argument with regard to tenure and one
of the strongest Arguments for tenure is
that it means that the scholar the
faculty member who has tenure
cannot be gone after on the basis that
his job is at risk by the administration
by his or her colleagues of course
tenure doesn't turn out to be the kind
of security that that we might have
thought it did as we as we learned
ourselves uh at Evergreen six six plus
years ago uh but that is what it is
supposed to do uh that that early in uh
faculty person's career if they are if
they are 10-year track which means that
they have the chance to secure tenure at
some point and you know this is putting
aside the fact that I think it's now a
majority of Faculty who aren't even
tenured cracks so that's just a whole
different kind of insecurity uh that is
being created by a system that is just
off the rails but an early career
10-year track a faculty member
may play it a little bit safe until they
get tenure at which point they are
supposed to know that they are free that
any fear that they had of Retribution
for investigating questions and problems
that are considered
figured out we've done that you don't
need to ask those questions anymore oh
that's not the kind of questions we ask
now oh good people don't ask those
questions well you know what I've now
got tenure I'm going to ask the
questions that interest me
that's supposed to be what 10-year
offers yes the problem of course as
we've discussed before is that this is a
system that trains people such that at
the point that they get tenure they have
no recollection of how they might use it
usefully and in fact during covid
the number of tenured academics who
stood up and said the obvious
was tiny tiny um because basically this
is a training program that is uh for
whatever reason built to ensure that
when you get tenure you won't use it yes
um so that is a tragedy and it's not an
argument against tenure itself it's an
argument against a system that functions
in such a way that it trains you not to
make use of it when you attain it
um it could be resurrected if you fixed
that aspect of the system but that would
have to be done uh quite deliberately
and at the moment it's uh
it's another one of these well-intended
programs that has unintended
consequences that render it worse than
useless yeah no I think I think that's
right and that's that is where I fall
now oh um actually with regard to tenure
and I'm shocked yeah find myself there
no it is it is necessary that something
do the job of creating a zone of safety
for uh Renegades because frankly they're
the ones who figure out where the future
is right
um
I wanted to point out a couple a couple
things
Evergreen as you well know
um was founded by true
radicals who threw out every single
component of a normal university that
wasn't
you know bolted to the floor
if you're at departments they threw out
uh tenure they built something parallel
to these things but not exactly the same
but they also changed the fundamental
logic of academic freedom
and you can you can hear it in that
quote that frankfur is uh is
giving voice to in in his opinion there
where the university has the right to
hire who it would hire and to say what
will be taught there and in what way it
will be taught that is not how Evergreen
Works be admitted to study right but at
Evergreen professors literally had the
right to choose what they wanted to
teach and in what way to teach it which
was a disaster when a professor wasn't
up to that challenge there was a lot of
bad teaching there but there was also a
lot of excellent teaching because the
administrators were not in a position to
tell the professors what to do and so a
good professor could make a lot of use
of that freedom so anyway that is a that
is I the way I see it now
that is effectively a libertarian view
of academic freedom right if
institutions are free to hire those that
they would hire to teach what they would
have taught in the ways that they want
it taught that's very different than the
individual they have hired being
liberated to teach whatever they think
needs to be taught in whatever manner
they feel like teaching it yeah no and
there's this
there's this incredible tension and I've
I've seen people who I understood to be
on one side politically come down very
strongly on the other side of this issue
and and in in both directions and I've
been
I guess I'm not so surprised anymore but
I've seen you know a vowed conservatives
um saying that the choices of what to
teach and how to teach it needs to be in
the hand of the administ in the hands
the administrators and
um my you know I I recoil at this this
is this is this is this is utter
Insanity on the other hand
given what so many faculty are thinking
now or failing to think and what they
think is passing for a scholarship and
what they are there for
um passing into the brains of students
well I don't I don't want those faculty
near you know the the fragile New Brains
of people that I care about either on
the other hand are the administrators
better no there's no there's no solution
of course they're not there's there's no
solution on that pairing what you need
is actually excellent independent-minded
creative analytically capable thinkers
who are not just Courageous about asking
questions but courageous but
confident enough in their own selves to
get up in front of a room of 18 year
olds or 25 year olds or whatever
and say Here's what we're talking about
today
we're talking about it because I chose
for us to be talking about it and I am
well versed in several aspects of it and
I expect that I know more than all of
you about most aspects of it but there
will be gaps in my knowledge
I will be wrong about some things and I
encourage you to think through what it
is that I'm saying and if you find those
gaps or those errors to respectfully
carefully don't make the sport out of
this but to bring those to my attention
and let's figure it out together because
the point here is figuring out what is
true and what is right not having you
the audience the students I just bow
down to me because I came in here with a
PhD and you know how rare are faculty
like that unfortunately extremely rare
well they are rare in part because of
the hegemony of a system that
has
constructed a mechanism for Distributing
Dogma in the guise of science right in
other words the university has been
broken for a very long time right it's
now in collapse and obviously so but
that was true the collapse was beginning
back when you and I were college
students we could see it yep and so what
happens if so who knows how long before
that right academic generation after
academic generation passes with a system
of power being used to train people not
to use tenure right so what you don't
have is a institution full of Scholars
who are used to you know rattling each
other's cages and you know discovering
errors and thinking and you know moving
the ball forward what they are is
compliant with a political order inside
the university that pretends to be
something else
so when they train their students those
students pick up this cowardice
and that's what we saw an epidemic of
cowardice in the University system in
the face of obvious nonsense that is
analytical nonsense which it was unable
to call out and it is not surprising
that two or three academic Generations
later you can say well
do I want the faculty empowered or do I
want the administrators I don't want any
of those idiots empowered right I want
something else I want people who
actually know what they're doing and
there aren't enough not that faculty not
those administrators and frankly and
this you know
I I was reminded of this
you and I have both talked about
the following many times
um you in part in front of Congress and
be in part at the Department of Justice
and
we are we have been asked you know less
so the longer it gets since the
Evergreen blow up but you know what what
do you have to say to the faculty what
do you have to say to the ministers what
do you have to say to the students and
so many people are like ah these
students they're so reprehensible they
just don't know what to do like you know
what
what we saw was that students were
reachable they're young yet they're not
ideologically captured increasingly they
are being more and more ideologically
captured because they're being preached
at in the K-12 system all right like
this you know even that is changing but
they're still less likely to be
ideologically captured uh than people
whose very careers depend on them
continuing to to spew the party line and
so you know administrators have a
particular set of jobs that they need to
do and you need to fix and faculty have
a ton of work to do and many of them are
not going to be savable honestly but
most of the students are most of the
students are but you have to meet them
with
with conviction that might change with
courage with respect and with pushback
when they say dumb things and everyone
will say dumb things
well we can so I would
I felt the entire time that we were
teaching uh college that on the one hand
it was marvelous what we were able to
accomplish we found lots and lots of
students who were very reachable and we
reached a great many on the other hand
it was an uphill battle at the point you
get to College because so much damage
had been done earlier this is true and
that the right place to intervene is you
know in grade school
right the the the system that damages
people as they Advance through the
supposed educational uh environment is
uh you know it robs you of the
developmental capacity and it may be
more fun to teach College in a sense
because the material is is richer but
it's the wrong place to to save people
right the system is broken early on and
what you have is a cascading failure
that at the point that you get to
college has people who are increasingly
empowered and
uh have been betrayed by those who told
them how you figure out what's true no
it's it's part of why what's happening
in K-12 is so it's is is so important
and uh you know the the obvious
the obvious obvious things around trans
ideology
um which actually threatened to and do
do physical uh irreparable damage to to
Children uh when it's taken to it's now
apparently accepted medical extent uh is
just it it's a perfect encapsulation of
the set of risks but even even absent
that
using children as Tools in your own
ideological battle as opposed to
giving children experience real physical
experience of the real physical world
and the tools to do the relatively few
things when they're very young that they
really will need to do like read and
write and do some math
and then get them outside gardening and
get them outside playing sports and have
them make art and have them consider
patterns
and try to figure out what it is that is
could possibly be causing those patterns
and when they propose ideas that you
know if they're five maybe you don't
call it a hypothesis but maybe you do we
certainly did with our kids when they're
10 you do and you reveal to them How
Deeply personally they feel about any
hypothesis they come up with even if
it's something they didn't even know
existed 10 minutes ago and it's that
sort of once you can begin once you can
begin to reveal to people how much
they've taken on a belief even one that
they didn't even know existed a few
minutes ago then you can be able to
separate for them the emotional sense of
like this like I will die if you don't
do this for me as opposed to maybe
that's just not true and that's okay so
let's move on
that's great but it's worse than that
I'm sorry I know that's inappropriate
here because what you've just described
is an excellent way of educating people
but the
the problem
many of our colleagues who are
comparatively awake to the problem in
the University system
see the perverse incentives and they see
the Meltdown and they think ah fix the
perverse incentives solve the Meltdown
they don't understand there aren't
enough people who are capable of doing
what you've just outlined right if you
were to solve the you know it's it's
tenure right tenure proves this point
yeah but you you I was talking about
college and you said no we have to talk
about K-12 and now you're talking about
college again well you wanted to talk
about the like the elementary school
kids well there's no there's no tenure
there it's the same it's the same point
the point is look at what tenure proves
about fix the incentives right a
professor who has immunity from their
colleagues dirty looks and negative
opinions
is a professor For Whom the incentive
structure has been fixed and they don't
behave courageously because they've been
developmentally trained not to so what
what we have is a system that begins
miseducating people in grade school
those people mature through the ranks
then they ultimately become professors
and
I I think that actually there's plenty
of elementary school teachers and people
who want to be Elementary School
teachers who can do what I send no you
could do that but how long would it take
you to solve the problem so that it
cascaded up and you had a system of
people in college who were actually
several Generations it takes several
Generations at least a generation why
would it take several why does it
inherently take several because it has
to spread because you say there are
enough people I don't think there are
enough people to staff every classroom
for every grade school there are enough
people that you might have a couple of
them in every school and those people
might be able to illustrate by example
what can be done and it might catch on
slowly but it's going to take a long
time for a good set of incentives to
pervade the system enough that we're
actually educating people rather than
anti-educating people which is what
we're currently doing
so
anyway
I think you and I are making different
points
my point is we have a four alarm fire
because there's no
fix for the one that I'm talking about
and what what can you describe I feel
like you've made two different points
and I don't know what fix you're talking
about now
the fix of civilization in which we are
training people to actually think
independently enough to spot wrong ideas
and see around them what we have is a
population that has become compliant at
best people have become reflexively
skeptical of what they're being told is
true but they don't know how to find I
would caution I would say cynical then
reflexively skeptical yeah yeah I agree
with you cynical is the right term but
you know you can't live in a society in
which you've got a bunch of people who
believe the Rabid Dogma
no matter what it says and how obviously
wrong it is and the other half of
society just simply won't believe
anything right but I mean I think this
this is
it is it is a different approach
to education but one that is done I mean
maybe not on in these terms exactly but
I know that there's elements of this
approach
in
um in the teachings in Rudolph Steiner
right and Waldorf in some of the you
know some of the unschooling like and
there's just I'm forgetting many of the
names of the Traditions at the moment
but there there are a number of these
and and they and they go up as well
there's some there's some institutions
of of higher ed that actively
are kind of you know take these low-tech
High nature High exposure to complexity
and high exposure to physical labor
honestly approaches to educating the
whole human being to not imagining that
you're just you know doing the analytics
so you're just I don't even know what
else it would be but
um you know this this concept if you
know for talking about higher ed now I
think most K-12 teachers don't make this
error anyway but it's amazing the number
of college faculty who who basically say
the students to me are brains and jars
like the whole rest of who they are what
it is that they you know that they are
and what informs them and why they're
here and why they care and what they're
doing next doesn't pertain to me that's
for student affairs like that's a
different division of the college that
that matters and that's absurd because
and but but that does follow from some
of the other confusions of modernity or
post-modernity if you will which
imagines that you can be a set you know
your body is separate from your brain is
separate from your psychology like all
of these things can actually be
separated out and you can say oh well
you know today I'm going to work out
because you know my body needs a workout
it's like no that's going to help
everything like you know everything that
you do is affecting everything that you
are and this reductionist approach to
education to science to understanding
who we are in the universe everything is
it's it's not just degrading but it
makes no sense it's totally incoherent
and I think I think the modern
educational approach of saying today you
know right now children what we're doing
is we're learning to write
right now children what we're learning
is how to garden and you know there will
be some of those things like actually
you should know your times tables right
um but in general the more holistic the
experience and the more you can be
called on at any moment to pull
something that you know from some domain
that you don't think you're working on
right now the more integrated all of
your understanding about the universe is
going to be and the more likely you are
going to be able to be competent to
solve problems
um under normal conditions and also in
an emergency and that's what we saw as a
failure for people to think in the
emergency that was this last three years
yeah it's a it's a a obvious
demonstration of the absence of the
capacity to think which is what we claim
we are
inducing in students and I have not
heard anybody any Professor say students
are effectively brains in jars but I
certainly have heard them two colleagues
who said that to me right I believe it I
just didn't hear it what I heard was was
the um
beautified version of that that doesn't
sound quite so despicable right it's the
packaged version which is life of the
Mind right the idea that we are the
academics and we have actually
discovered that the richness of life is
what takes place in your mind and it is
disconnected from the world and you have
to participate in the world to an extent
but it's to be minimized because really
what the experience is is the extraction
of high-minded ideas I'm sorry like this
is the Ivory Tower right this is White
Collar versus Blue Collar this is you
know hating on the body and anyone who
does work with their body and you know
meanwhile these people are presumably
thinking them many of them like oh I'm
also a foodie I care very much about
like you don't know anything these
people often don't know anything because
they are so disconnected I'm sorry I
like no no I hate this so much I detest
it equally but
you know I I hate to keep returning us
here but we've got a particular kind of
failure that we have now seen again and
again and it looks like this you've got
a system that operates on momentum yeah
you disrupt it in a fundamental way
because you're a corrupt son of a
and you want the system to you know to
take your particular idea and propagate
it because it will make you wealthier
whatever okay so you disrupt the ability
of the system to spot garbage because
you want to distribute your particular
kind of garbage through that system
and then hold on that sounded a little
bit too cynical I think most people
don't start by saying I'm going to
produce garbage and I'm going to make
sure the system they start by producing
something and
um and it's good and then they produce
another thing and it's not as good and I
think well but still but it's the thing
I just spent a year on and it needs to
get accepted and so you know it's it's
not the goal isn't let's get the system
to produce to accept garbage no no I'm
talking about something different I
agree with you that what you're talking
about is real and that most people start
out intending to do good work and they
turn into uh counterproductive
automatons through a developmental
process I'm talking about something like
uh Pharma which discovers
that not only does it need for
scientists to say untrue things on its
behalf but that it can become expert at
refining what it is that the scientists
will On Cue say in order to get the
products of Pharma consumed and it
becomes uh a puppeteer right so that is
diabolical whatever the internal
conversations it
it's a virtuoso right it plays the
university and uh the public basically
the hospital agencies everything all of
these things plays them like an
orchestra yeah um
but
so you figured let's say that there's
some Pharma thing which needs its
message broadcast through people wearing
the right kind of guard with the right
kinds of degrees and the right kinds of
venues
and the right accents and the right all
of the the the proper uh you know the
props and the settings and everything
yeah so it disrupts the ability of the
university to figure out what's true
because if the university starts looking
at what it's supposed to be saying on
behalf of Pharma and says hey wait a
minute that doesn't even make sense
because here are 17 different reasons
that we should be skeptical of it right
um that will be bad so it gets good at
playing the university and everything
connected to it uh like an instrument
and
it does not result in a catastrophe
right away right the university stopped
thinking we don't know exactly when that
happened but it did and the point is
it's Generations later when you notice
right when the thing is so bad that you
can now talk about in public hey that is
an institution that has completely
collapsed even though if you stood in
the center of any campus it would still
look like a functioning University right
you still see the professors you see the
students you see the books you see that
everything that you would expect to see
is there except for the style of
thinking that results in Insight right
so
when you what is the name the hardest
thing to quantify though right and which
is why it was we were in denial and you
and I were not in denial we were
complaining about the failure of those
institutions though maybe we were not
complaining uh at the correct level
given the degree of uh of failure but we
saw it yeah but what's the name for the
thing when you wreck you have a perverse
incentive that causes you to wreck the
competence of an institution that then
continues to do its job because it
doesn't require competence for some
period of time and then you notice way
down the road hey repeat the inspectors
of this kind of engineering stopped
checking anything I mean we saw it in
the financial crisis with the ratings
agencies the ratings agencies were
giving ratings that had nothing to do
with the quality of the the financial
instrument right so it's like oh the
ratings agency this is
critically important and I
I don't know that that has a name I want
I want to hear about it if if it does
the the there's an institution that is
uh important if not perhaps even
necessary to the functioning of a
society as we understand it
it gets captured broken something but it
continues on because it's already got
momentum inertia and
it is not noticed it is a shell of
itself it is perhaps even in this case
in many cases doing the opposite of what
it's supposed to do what it is
continuing to claim to do and it
continues on for some time and
honestly because it's still going by the
same name and because the thing that it
was supposed to be doing is a little
hard to track
uh and because there is some other in
the in this case there is some other
entity out there that wants no one to
notice do not look at the man behind the
curtain
it just continues on and
I mean I think
I think we're saying this all over we're
seeing it all over and two points one
our current president
is a very special version of this right
it is now totally obvious that the
person inhabiting the office is actually
an unnecessary prop
right this is an unnecessary prop and
you know the country's still bubbles
along right yeah yeah who is that what
who's really in charge right what does
this mean so anyway
a we got some style of problem where the
thing moves along based on momentum
ultimately a crisis emerges that reveals
how feeble it has become at which point
people become serious about fixing it
but what they don't spot is that there
is no fix at the point you've let the
thing go for Generations your fix is
going to take generations and that is
the disaster and then then there will be
the people who tried in and say but we
need X
and you say yes but that isn't X but we
need the institutions but we need the
media but we need the journalism but we
need the medical fixes for the deadly
diseases yes but those aren't fixes and
those aren't universities and that's not
media they're not doing journalism
they're not seeking truth they're not
curing the things they're claiming to
cure none of those things are what they
seem to be and so when you Trot in
saying oh we need those things like no
we need things that were once called
that but we don't have those things
anymore and the things that are
pretending to be them are doing far more
harm than good yeah we see it at
Wikipedia uh we see it at the CDC we see
it all over the place but we need a CDC
brat that very well may be but the
people to staff a CDC are not at the CDC
I'm not saying none of them are there
are some people inside the CDC inside
the Congress there are people everywhere
who could be liberated and would start
doing the job if given that opportunity
but there aren't enough of it to run
these things that's that's the concern
is that actually not even not currently
in the institutions but anywhere yes or
you know they how would you even find
them right if they're not credentialed
in the way you would expect also at some
level we've got a hiring problem like
it's a global level like how do you find
the talent for the all of all of the
institutions that actually need to be
functional that are not functional
and get those match those people with
those positions and give them the
authority to do what needs to be done
right it's a nightmare problem yeah and
I think I think I've spotted what I was
getting at
there are every one of these problems
where you discover an institution that
has been running on momentum at the
point a crisis that reveals its
incapacity emerges out of nowhere right
these are problems for which bad
incentives were enough to cause the
problem and good incentives are not
enough to fix it that's the problem it's
the asymmetry it was much easier to
cause this disruption than it is to to
fix it it's a basic yeah like
institutional entropy right you have
created institutions that cannot be
resurrected by reversing the things that
ruin them in the first place yeah you
cannot as I've said of the universities
just scrape the woke off the top right
not sufficient the rod is far deeper
than that yep
yeah
well that's fun yeah
okay
um change the topic sure uh did you want
to do a thought experiment or do you
want me to talk about uh cancer research
first uh I would like to do a thought
experiment but um in light of the
darkness of where we have just been I
want to take a brief interlude and uh so
yesterday was Independence Day as we've
mentioned that was kind of a poignant
moment for us it ended uh with uh the
most amazing uh firework show I've ever
seen oh my car by far by far was not
expecting that we live in a you know on
an island small town I was expecting a
little fireworks display which would be
kind of cool if this was all the way the
four of us like whoa what happened
but earlier in the day
um
uh
we moved into a place that had a garden
that was fully overgrown when we moved
in and that Garden you have been
resurrecting uh at a flower garden not a
food Garden right not a food Garden but
a flower garden that to me looked like
it was gonna be it was going to need to
be just totally dug up and new stuff put
in there was it was overgrown but the
person who had initially put it in was
quite a thoughtful person apparently a
very yeah the woman whose home it was
um before she died who was now she died
in her 80s yeah uh but she she was
apparently an amazing woman an amazing
woman apparently maybe a pilot yeah uh
anyway a person with an incredible life
story who had obviously put I think she
had tremendous gardening insight and um
sort of you know the the approach so far
has been get rid of the obvious things
that we don't want the grass that shows
up yeah and and just and wait and see
what else and see what else will come up
and it's been remarkable it's been
remarkable so anyway uh there's this
little miracle that has emerged this
spring for us it's our first spring in
the place and
um
you know we knew we had hummingbirds
which is cool there's only a couple of
species of hummingbirds up here but
they're both you know all hummingbirds
are cool and these guys are especially
uh behaviorally interesting
um and anyway the garden has become a
little Paradise for bumblebees and
hummingbirds and so anyway uh I I love
photographing hummingbirds and I haven't
done very much in the tempered Zone
because
there aren't it's just hard to do yeah
but in our garden it's become possible
so yesterday uh I decided to see if I
could capture hummingbirds But It's
tricky in our garden because in most
Gardens there's like a plant that
attracts hummingbirds if you can spot it
you can set up on a tripod get ready for
the bird to come and if you're lucky you
get it in our garden you never know
where the bird's going to be because
there's so much going on there's a lot
there are a lot of species the
hummingbirds go for but there's also
what seems to be their favorite is this
toad flax and we've got just a lot of
spiers of toad flax so anyway yesterday
I decided to see if I could do it
handheld I would just figure out where
the bird was and see if I could catch it
and Zach do you want to show I got a
bunch of really good pictures but anyway
um so I believe this is a female Rufus
hummingbird and a Rufus hummingbird is
an amazing animal they're migratory
route is from deep in Mexico and they
range up to Alaska oh my God in the
summer
um so anyway they're all do you know are
all the populations
um migratory or some of them residents I
believe all of them are migratory I'm
not an expert on this species but that's
what I think is going on here and so
here you have this beautiful female
hummingbird drinking nectar from this
toad flax uh in this amazing Garden
planted by this now
now gone uh very insightful woman and I
I think it's pretty clear that she was
fond of hummingbirds herself and planted
uh to attract them
so anyway I thought I would wonderful
apologize for the people who are just
listening
um
but this is a beautiful animal it is uh
what a privilege to get to see them yeah
what a beautiful photograph right thank
you nice to see it on Independence Day
too that felt right yeah
okay
um onto the thought experiment and it's
just a brief thought experiment but it
dawned on me uh
actually at the parade that we went to
uh yesterday the New Year's nope uh how
about Independence Day Parade
in which there was a group of uh
disabled uh
[Music]
athletes I think
I'm not sure in any case it's bird of
thought
um which was if you take the logic
whereby uh trans women that is to say
people born male who uh declare
themselves female and are now competing
in women's sports and you map it onto
the Special Olympics why is it would it
be permitted to declare oneself disabled
in order to compete in the Special
Olympics and the reason that I think
this is a useful thought experiment is
that that would obviously be a
Despicable Behavior you know if you
decided that what you really wanted was
a gold medal in something and you
declared yourself disabled and then you
beat some actually disabled people and
you ascended to the podium and then gave
your interview and said how proud you
were and how hard you had worked right
everybody would presumably in 2023 look
at you like what the hell are you doing
yeah right that's not cool it's
despicable that's despicable this is an
institution
that exists for a purpose and you know
that purpose is interesting it turns out
the Special Olympics were founded by uh
so I just pulled it out I found it in
1968 by Eunice Kennedy driver yep
um and you know I I found it a little
hard to find a precise description of
exactly what she was
um doing but I think it's pretty clear
that we can make the following argument
do you want to know what so she says
founded in 1968 by Eunice candy Shriver
Special Olympics provides people with
intellectual disabilities continuing
opportunities to realize their potential
develop physical fitness demonstrate
courage and experience joy and
friendship and then under the facts it's
a little bit small
um who is eligible eligible to
participate yeah share it yeah yeah um
to be eligible to participate in Special
Olympics you must be at least eight
years old and identified by an agency or
professional as having one of the
following conditions intellectual
disabilities cognitive delays is
measured by formal assessment or
significant learning or vocational
problems due to cognitive delay that
require or have required specially
designed instruction
so that identified by an agency or
professional as having an intellectual
disability for instance now given that
professionals are identifying boys as
girls and girls as boys
why not why not why not and the answer
is in 2023 why not is pretty obvious
because it would be despicable however
it's despicable for boys to be called
girls in order to compete in women's
sports right and so I did want to so
there's there's obviously a important
distinction here the reason that the
Mind bridles at the idea of uh abled
person declaring themselves disabled
getting an institution or a professional
to sign on and going and beating
actually disabled people in order to get
uh Awards yeah all right the reason that
that is uh
not something that we can accept in 2023
is that
[Music]
um
we still Reserve in our minds a
position of protection for a person who
is intellectually disabled in this
regard right some kind of uh
I I hope I'm not using an offensive term
but some kind of pity would cause us I
think still in 2023 to defend such
people and women are not
incapacitated men this is an entirely
different phenomenon what women are is
optimized for a different subset of
roles in biology that means that in
almost all sports women and men cannot
compete directly with each other fairly
right
um and so there is a slight distinction
here but I believe it is a distinction
without a difference because what has
happened is we built women's sports
precisely because half of the population
was perfectly capable of benefiting from
Sport and competing vigorously in sport
but not if we you know did it all in one
uh mixed grouping and so that was
progress that was progress and it
created the ability for all of the good
things that follow from sport to reach
half of the population right
by breaching that boundary in some sort
of uh
ill-begotten attempt to protect some
tiny number of people from some
uh largely imagined
hazard right is obviously upside down
and backwards but I just think by you
know and thought experiments I have to
say we have to be careful with because
many people do not understand their
proper logical status they are not
experiments as if you have run them in a
laboratory they are not validations of
something or in the field uh yeah they
are not validations of uh what will
happen if you did run such an experiment
but they are useful
um a to uh predict what might happen and
then find out or in order to explore
territory where you can't run an
experiment right
so I don't know what will happen here I
don't know if we will ultimately find uh
terrible people who misunderstand what
the
nature of Pride actually is and seek to
be proud of themselves for winning an
award they are not entitled to by
beating people who uh are disabled and
therefore competing in the Special
Olympics but I wouldn't rule out the
possibility that we're going there I
mean we basically I don't see why not
destroyed every kind of logic there is
we you know now cannot agree that two
plus two equals four that men cannot
become women that pedophilia is bad you
and I can
you and I can and presumably uh
most of our audience maybe all of our
audience saved for the few haters uh can
agree on these things but we
civilizationally cannot figure out how
to shut down the sophists and the
cheaters who wish to use our inability
to precisely articulate exactly why in
this instance you are not allowed to do
X right that's what they're doing again
and again and this is the case and back
to your point that it's much easier to
destroy than to build
yeah it's another it's another kind of
uh
institutional entropy yeah um and I will
say I was
um when I went looking at the special
Olympic site I was as now happens so
frequently
uh
confused emotionally confused at some of
what I read because things that 10 years
ago would yeah go to the front page of
their site things that 10 years ago
would not have struck me at all would
have struck me as just normal
um
there it is what is it the revolution is
inclusion oh oh hello right now the
revolution is inclusion this is the
Special Olympics they're just
but I can read that both ways I can read
that as
um
the Special Olympics are heroic people
who are
looking to include people whose quality
of life would otherwise be lower because
of course why do we care less about the
quality of life of a mentally disabled
person and it is wonderful that there's
an organization that wishes to to give
them the kinds of rewards that come from
vigorous participation in sports and
isn't it amazing that this works right
yeah on the other hand I can read that
uh inclusion as a code word yeah and the
point is is that word setting them up
for well
why is the Special Olympics excluding
certain people who wish to participate
and you know here I have a person who
this institution has declared disabled
and you know I could see that happening
so
yeah no I mean
inclusion starts out as an idea uh that
makes
Good Sense intuitive sense moral sense
but what it actually means is we've had
a group with rigid boundaries and we've
been excluding some people and so now we
want to open it up but that doesn't mean
that
every
competition every meeting every
organization has to have its doors wide
open to everyone
just as just as a nation state is
allowed to have borders
uh a
Women's Basketball team is allowed to
say no man allowed if you're a group of
neighborhood kids you're allowed to
build a tree house and say no boys or no
girls
like we're allowed to create groups for
ourselves and organizations with
missions in this case specifically for
those people who had been excluded from
competitive sport before right and is it
possible that someone could come along
and say ah I don't have an intellectual
disability but I want to participate
it's hard to imagine at this point
anyone would be would fall for it but
given what has happened to women's
sports why not and then given what has
happened to the so-called professionals
who would diagnose such a thing of
course
if you're willing to diagnose a girl as
a boy why would you not diagnose totally
normal intellectual functioning as a
disability of some sort we know that's
happening and then use that as a ticket
to entry into the Special Olympics
so
um I Have Become
uh
very careful in my thinking around
Liberty
I think this is a an idea a concept that
is both fundamentally important as many
people realize and in which the
Precision surrounding our understanding
of it is where it either does great good
or great harm and so anyway I've just
I've distinguished in my mind between
Liberty something that you're
technically free to do
and realized Liberty something that
you're in a position to act on right
and
one of the things that I've noticed is
that there there is a paradox which we
have to get good at thinking about which
is good rules which restrict Liberty
that's what rules do yes right increase
realized Liberty right good rules that
should be their purpose right in fact
ultimately you can make a strong
argument that the success of a society
can be judged based on its effect on
realized Liberty now you have to
integrate over future Generations too we
can't Rob future generations of the
ability to do stuff in order to be more
liberated in the present so that's a
potential loophole that you got to be
careful about but a society that
actually produces increased levels of
realized Liberty for its citizens going
forward is a successful Society
and the point I want to make is that the
rules that exclude people-born male from
competing in women's sports people who
are able competing in the Special
Olympics these are things that clearly
increase realized Liberty by excluding
right as soon as you let men into
women's sports there's no women's sports
we're back where we were before women's
sports right men will destroy women's
sports
women having Sports is how many people
are women gee it seems like a lot of
them right do you think any of them
would be interested in playing sports
yeah again a lot yeah right do we need
sports for them it seems like a huge
benefit to Society for women to be able
to get the benefits of sport so the
point is we need a rule that keeps
people from destroying women's sports by
claiming a liberty
that's very interesting I I think I want
to chew on that a little bit more this
you know Liberty versus realized Liberty
yes I agree with what you've said
I I'm not sure that the advantages that
are accrued by the exclusion
um I guess in a ledger that I have in my
head that's not I don't have it yet I
you know I also have Justice and safety
as you know as categories right so
uh the my my now long-term relationship
with this concept of Liberty is about
the reason that I see it as special is
that it integrates the others
right so in other words yeah I thought
that was what you were doing and it's
like it's an aggregate term it isn't it
is an integrative value and therefore
this is the place so I I used to be
um I think too hard on the ideological
Libertarians right because their focus
on Liberty is often I think more closely
aligned with uh theoretical Liberty and
they can be dismissive of rules that
create uh greater realized Liberty but
what I think they have right and I think
they actually have very right is that if
you were gonna pick one
that's the one because it's integrative
right you need a rich realized version
of Liberty but if you just maximize
realized Liberty then the point is oh
you take care of all the other stuff
because you're not liberated if you're
um you know dying of cancer because you
breathed pollutants right so the point
is rules that free your lungs of the
pollutants that will cause them to
produce a cancer are Liberty enhancing
if you instantiate Liberty correctly
um so anyway there's yep
there's something there but you know I
the the ultimate version of this the
first one I realized was uh how much
Liberty do we get from the ability to
get on an airplane in one part of the
world and within hours be any other part
of the world we want that's an amazing
level of realized Liberty right it comes
from an absolutely ruthless set of rules
surrounding the safety of aircraft right
right and you wouldn't want to be in a
wild west of aircraft where they were
falling out of the sky all the time
because the cheapest tickets uh were to
the carriers that were cutting the most
corners and maintenance right you want
an FAA that works and you want
International bodies that work and that
you know agree on the rules of you know
altitudes and you know air traffic
control and all that stuff good
regulations and good Regulators increase
realized Liberty Bingo that's the thing
Libertarians but let's say about
it I bet they do
yeah and the devil's in the details yeah
you know what good like defining it
which depends on what the definition of
good is
darn but yeah it does well it's one of
these things this is another uh useful
piece of analytical toolkit is there are
lots of things that you can figure out
uh accurately and you can nail them but
you cannot operationalize them easily
right understanding what's true about
the thing is easy understanding how you
manifest that as a set of uh you know
rules and structures that implements it
is much harder given that it's going to
be entirely Apes doing the
implementation oh that's not good it's
gonna be really massive have you met
Apes a few
yeah yeah it's the Apes it's the Apes
that are the problem yeah
um not that if somehow it had been
Dolphins I think it would be any better
no whatever point they got to our level
of technological and postmodern certain
things would be better
um
Forest would probably be safer the force
would be safer and uh the Dolphins would
give each other the finger less often
everything back never yes yeah never
never they might have yeah they'd give
each other the flipper but
yeah okay
good
let's look a little bit and I really
don't want to go deep on the science and
part because there's two new pieces of
science out um that the papers aren't
available to those of us who have been
thrown out of Academia cyhub doesn't
have them up yet um so we just have the
abstracts and but really the point is I
was made aware in nature news which is
the like news or news arm of nature
again one of the world's two supposed
best science journals
um this week they reported that uh and
I'll come back to this piece but for
right now I'll just tell you the
headline
excuse me how the Y chromosome makes
some cancers more deadly for men two
studies help to explain why colorectal
and bladder tumors take a bigger toll on
men than on women
okay yep
so I went to
God fallen's getting to me a little bit
too I think sorry to hear that uh
so the research that nature news is
citing uh is here's one of them
this is uh the just beautifully named
histone dimethylase KD m5d upregulation
drives sex differences in colon cancer
again published in nature June 21st
and all we have is the abstract again
it's not available to those of us not
affiliated with
um
fancy institutions at the moment
they begin by saying sex exerts a
profound impact on cancer incidents
spectrum and outcomes and there's
actually some other really good research
I found that that really you know
clarifies like to what degree is this
lifestyle across many cancers like you
know what it's you can't attribute all
the differences in cancer rates to
different decisions that men and women
make like the fact that men are more
likely to smoke and more likely to tell
you to hold their beer while they do
something stupid doesn't fully explain
the difference the contents of the
subreddit why women live longer is not
fully explanatory
yes so so now there's some research
trying to figure out okay so what might
be the things that are actually going on
that are attributable to you know
underlying sex differences
and uh they you know this is a model
yada
um
uh let's see they say
boy I can't even figure out where okay
take my screen off for a moment here so
I can look at my notes
um I believe
do I have this I don't even have this in
the notes okay so that one
um is
basically finding
um that a particular Y chromosome Gene
not Y chromosomes generally but why a
particular Gene that is found on the Y
chromosome raises the risks of some
colorectal cancer spreading other parts
of the body now it's a model it's a
mouse model
I would also point out surprising
because the Y chromosome in mammals uh
is not a well-populated chromosome the
logic that is frequently advanced in
evolutionary circles is that the rest of
the genome can't trust the Y chromosome
and has therefore shut it down so that
it encodes primarily just the gene that
turns you mail so
so precisely the other piece of research
so which is this one
also published same day last week or
week and a half ago whenever in nature
why chromosome loss in cancer drives
growth by evasion of adaptive immunity
wait wait wait wait let me think about
that why chromosome loss in cancer
drives growth by evasion of adaptive
immunity so let's this abstract actually
is a little bit less ridiculously
written so let's let's work through it a
little bit yeah
um loss of the Y chromosome Loi loss of
the Y chromosome is observed in multiple
cancer types as you just said including
10 to 40 percent of bladder cancers but
it's clinical and biological
significance is unknown here using
genomic and transcript transcriptomic
studies we report that loss of the Y
chromosome correlates with poor
prognosis in patients with bladder
cancer
We performed in-depth studies of
naturally occurring loss of Y chromosome
mutant bladder cancer cells as well as
those with targeted dilution of Y
chromosome by crispr cas9
why positive and Y negative tumors grew
similarly in vitro whereas why negative
tumors were more aggressive than why
positive tumors in immune competent
house and T Cell dependent manner so and
and this is the first time you're seeing
this
yeah I'm wondering
so I don't know where this goes yeah and
again I don't have the full paper I just
have the abstract okay so here here's
what I think a there's an interesting
question I actually mentioned this
question to Grider back when before she
had uh pretended she didn't know me yeah
and then she went on and did some work
on it actually
um the question is okay telomeres
regulate how many cell divisions uh you
get to make but you've got a bunch of
different chromosomes which telomeres it
is that the average is the shortest
whatever yeah possible that the Y
chromosome which has a special telomeric
implication because you will you will
recall I got very excited one day when I
was doing the telomere library work
because I found
that there was evidence that
telomeres of
sperm
produced by older fathers have longer
telomeres and the reason that that's
interesting is that it provides a
mechanism for a an individual to
discover some information about how safe
the world they are in is and to convey a
degree of longevity to offspring on the
basis of it so there's a trade-off
between Cancer suppression and Longevity
and the point is in a very dangerous
environment you don't worry so much
about longevity because you probably
won't live to benefit from it so you
worry more about cancer suppression so
if you found that you were in a very
safe environment where your Offspring
could potentially live a very long time
then you might imbue them with longer
telomeres so that their tissues could
replace themselves better at some extra
risk of cancer
so if the Y chromosome is specially
implicated in a mechanism for censusing
the world to figure out whether or not
it's a moment for longer or shorter
telomeres in offspring
then the Y chromosome loss here might be
I guess I would expect it to be earlier
in the Cascade I would expect
telomere I would expect the loss of the
Y chromosome to liberate cells to
produce more copies which would then
predispose to cancer but I guess I
wouldn't necessarily expect the cancers
to be more immune evasive so again again
we don't have the full paper together
these results demonstrate that cancer
cells with loss of the Y mutations alter
T cell function promoting T Cell
exhaustion and sensitizing them to pd1
targeted immunotherapy so that implant
that implied the T Cell exhaustion
unless I'm mistaken is the result of the
fact that t and this is actually covered
in in the paper that Debbie and I
ultimately wrote on this topic
T and B cells have a special predicament
with respect to how many cell divisions
they go through right because the
progenitors of the tnb cells most of
them are like Bank guards that go their
whole career and never get triggered so
they don't have to do a lot of cell
division but if you have a pathology
that is causing a particular subset of T
cells to react they have to proliferate
tremendously because the way that they
get better at fighting the disease is
through clonal selection so you have to
have a huge amount of proliferative
capacity for those small set of cells
that gets triggered which is part of why
lymphoma and Leukemia are likely cancers
because you have a tissue in which you
have to turn down the cancer protection
in order to get the immunity so what
they're describing with respect to T
Cell exhaustion is that the limits on
the reproduction of B and T cells are
very high but they're not infinite right
and so you can exhaust the capacity of a
particular subset of these cells to
react and if that subset is necessary to
fight a particular cancer then the
cancer gets liberated by exhausting
those cells
yes
that's right
a little interesting yeah so
fascinating
uh I wish that we could say more and I
think you've already I think intuited a
lot from just just that one abstract and
I'm not going to go back into the other
one
um
the research may be exciting it does
seem to be data driven rather than
hypothesis driven it does seem to be at
considerable risk of concluding
something and you know in the in the
first piece of research it's a gene on
the Y
um that causes cancer it's the other one
is the like it's it's the loss of the Y
that is indicative here and they're
going in opposite directions right like
ish not exactly because it's a gene on
the Y not the Y
um and you know the nature news article
says taken together the two studies are
a step toward understanding why so many
cancers have a bias towards men taken
together what are you talking about
right they they're not supporting one
another right but they're both about the
Y chromosome
they're both about you know they're both
about sex based differences in cancer
rates so I I wonder I think you're on to
something when you point out this is
data driven now hypothesis driven and
even if it were hypothesis driven it
would be narrowly mechanistically
hypothesis or not evolutionarily which
means that whatever Downstream applied
medical benefits that happen as a result
of This research are going to be narrow
reductionist and
as at least as likely to be dangerous as
helpful
yeah
like brought like at a gross level going
opposite directions with regard to it's
the why that's doing it to you oh it's
the loss of the Y that's doing it to you
like well okay different cancers
different situations like do not make a
decision based on this if you're not
also aware of what's going on over here
right yeah
um in this case I'm wondering
uh one of the
coolest pieces of logic that uh came out
of the telomere work was why
early sunburns are more likely to cause
a cancer which happens late in life than
late sunburns yeah and the idea you will
recall was that because you have more
cell divisions left before you run out
of telomere a mutation that causes a
cell line to run away and reproduce
without regulation produces a bigger
patch of cells that can then get a
second mutation that turns it into a
tumor
so one possibility is that the loss of
the Y is actually a
red herring here because what's happened
is a cell that goes on to be a Cancer
and therefore be noticed by people who
study cancer is one that escaped
telomere regulation by the why if the Y
is disproportionately likely to be the
chromosome that limits cell divisions
that sets the hayflick limit for those
cells then a cell that had lost its y
would create a bigger prototumor and it
would be more likely to become a tumor
which would be more likely to be noticed
by people who study tumors and therefore
it may be Downstream of it was the loss
of the Y that triggered the tumor in the
first place or increased the likelihood
of it it wasn't the loss of the Y that
was involved in the immune evasion right
right so I don't know super interesting
super interesting there's a lot more to
be done there I mean this
this whole area actually has some
intriguing stuff around for instance
um imprinting uh you know so genomic
imprinting meaning that some genes
actually keep keep track of
um you know scarecrows keep track of
which parent they came from and so
there's been some research I won't be
able to pull it up right now so let me
see if I can remember Turner syndrome
which is where uh a a female baby only
has one X
uh and so is X O X naught um at that
23rd position
um apparently you can they some research
has been done now which can track okay
but is your ex maternally derived or
paternally derived like which X are you
missing and so with regard to looking at
um you know it so and does the body keep
track when you have a a girl child with
turner syndrome who got her ex from Mom
and is missing an ex from Dad
she is likely to be less intellectually
impaired than when she only has the X
from Dad
so you know the the imprinting is is
there and it's it's tracking what parent
it came from and maternally inherited
versus paternally inherited x's in girl
children with only one X
um are less impaired
so a lot to think about right biology is
very interesting I don't know if you've
ever noticed that super interesting and
complex so this like I that was a paper
I was actually able to find so that's
the one I read as opposed to the
abstracts
um on this but
the stupid punch line of all of this
yeah okay the incredibly stupid
punchline other than you know as opposed
to the science
um
which we would like to be talking about
is
here let me see if I can find it
um okay here's the um nature news
article
how the Y chromosome makes some cancers
more deadly for men cool two studies
help to explain why colorectal and
bladder tumors are worse than men than
women
not very far into this article however
is the following parenthetical
this article uses men to describe people
with a Y chromosome while recognizing
that not all people who identify as men
have a y chromosome and not all people
who have a y chromosome identify as men
thank you for that
oh that's very clarifying
oh that's
yeah
so I mean at one level thank you
idiot nature for sending you know us
into a path of now there's some stuff to
think about with regard to cancer and
telomeres and there's some stuff I'm not
thinking about regard to genomic
imprinting
um and but that
that line there in this article that is
explicitly about sex differences I mean
All Is Lost like how how to to the point
that we've been making this entire
episode how could we possibly recover
all right think about it when they put
that that sentence into a piece about
this research all right so
you go to a coral reef
now please can I okay you dive under the
water and you open your eyes things are
blurry as hell yeah right
for obvious reasons we won't go into
somebody hands you a mask right masks
are clarifying right nature supposed to
be clarifying but nature has become like
a mask that somebody has loaded with mud
right it's like you have a mud mask that
you are attempting to look and it is not
as clarifying as perhaps it once was and
uh perhaps yeah maybe not perhaps the
mud is not as clarifying as the mask
pretty much these people should get a
grip and they should uh go back to
science and stuff because that was
better
don't even know what to do with this
you know what it is
that is a science don't hurt me wall
you remember you don't hurt me yeah for
sure so you know at the point that the
Portland broke down explicitly and had
protests every day that reliably for 100
nights straight turned into riots every
night and there was mass destruction
and people started putting up these
signs basically these black lives matter
signs all over their storefronts and I
called them don't hurt me walls and I
and I um you know pictures of a lot of
them we talked about them on air and you
know that's largely what they look like
some of these people were True Believers
um and but it doesn't really matter if
they were or not they were putting these
up as as a as a form of Contrition and
basically and some in some cases they
were literally begging like I'm a female
owned business I'm a bipod business
donor me I'm on the side of justice and
you know whatever they were don't hurt
me Wells
um
I don't
I'm afraid not here I I think that
nature is captured
oh I believe it is it's captured but
from the point of view of you okay
you've got a piece of research maybe
yeah
make some cancers more deadly for men I
mean first of all people realize
something
if you rob us of the ability to talk
about males and females in simple terms
and we start taking seriously the idea
that if you say you're a man then you
are then the point is we are actually
going to lose the ability to analyze
data to find patterns that are important
to for example our health yes right and
who is most likely to be harmed by this
it's going to be women historically the
people most likely to be harmed by like
oh let's just treat them all like the
same it doesn't matter meant that the
research was done on one class of people
and it mostly was men
it's going to hurt everybody I mean I I
I agree with you that there's a special
risk for women but the we are it is
literally I mean it's it's like the the
the mouse telomere problem right
the mouse telomere problem is a wicked
problem because it actually means that
whatever you study in these creatures
has a big old asterisk on it that
nobody's aware of and so the point is
you are now becoming Blinder the more
things you stack on top of broken mice
the more you don't know what you're
talking about and so this is another hey
you keep playing that game here you're
not going to know what you're talking
about 10 years from now you're not gonna
be able to know what the data means and
you're frankly handing a super weapon to
the sophists who are going to claim that
this sex stuff is all made up in the
first place because the data is going to
reflect chaos right total chaos yeah you
can have women who only get to say
they're chest feeding and men who get to
breastfeed and you know just just
complete Insanity across the board we
used to think that the Y chromosome
turned you into a male but now you can
see in the data that lots of people with
Y chromosomes are females
that's what it's going to say
right it's going to be impossible to
make normal sense if you let this stuff
into science nature sell these other
places so for sake people stop it
that's right right our ability to make
sense to each other is at stake and you
guys are playing games with it and you
have no right yeah just before you have
something to say but put the screen back
up just so people can see it again the
the Counterpoint between the headline of
this nature news article and the
highlighted uh the highlighted sentence
yeah I think this is then admitting that
they destroyed the ability to report
anything scientifically and so they're
going to redefine the terms as they was
what they actually mean using the woke
terminology but they I think there were
a number of these articles that actually
used
completely incorrect definitions of
everything and you couldn't get any
information across that's right and so
they've actually made it so the rest of
the article can kind of work here yeah
it's just and it's apparent it's
literally a parenthetical they've
literally said like and yeah what that
what that is supposed to mean a
parenthetical is the work could exist
with the same meaning without this thing
yeah right and so at one level maybe
this is this is like the necessary nod
this is the don't hurt me wall as you as
as you suggested I think I'm coming
around to that perspective this is like
the little tiny don't hurt me bit yep
and and by literally putting that in
parentheses they have said and you could
just ditch this and the same meaning
obtains throughout the rest of the
article and it does and in fact you need
to ditch it else you can't take this
seriously and you know the rest of the
discriminate you know I don't think this
was
I do I do have concerns about the
research it's reporting on as we talked
about uh but it it doesn't seem to be
suffused with wokeries other than that
parenthetical because they discovered
that that doesn't work for this at all
you can't do it you you can't talk about
this research if you don't know what a
man is
the funny thing is okay the first part
of what we talked about here yeah
is completely fascinating and the
pattern is bound if you can figure out
why the pattern is what it is
it is bound
to
make us much smarter about these very
important topics like cancer right
cancers that are difficult to treat so
the idea that we instead of focusing on
this very difficult puzzle what is the
meaning of cancers that are lacking a y
chromosome why would that be is that
because they're them becoming cancers
was the result of them losing a why and
evading a hay flick limit or not that's
an interesting question that has it's
consequential for our understanding of
cancer right instead we're going to talk
about the stuff that isn't consequential
for anything other than how confused
we're going to be in the future right
yeah and that's insane so I mean look
there are very good people who are
studying in a parallel area I would
point out uh Bernie crespi and Kyle
Summers have done some very interesting
work on the evolutionary Dynamics inside
of cancers which is a very fascinating
topic because a cancer uh basically dies
with you and so so the evolutionary
Dynamics are bounded within the short
period of time that the cancer is uh
present and unless unless it's
contagious
right I will bet you that a lot more
cancers turn out to be this as well but
whether they do it they don't the idea
that there's a whole branch of
evolutionary science that is about the
short period of time between the
instantiation of a Cancer and the death
of the patient
um this is a perfect place to have that
conversation and it has real
implications for how you treat these
things so you know let's Elevate the
burning crespies and the Kyle Summers of
the world and get those questions
addressed rather than this lunacy over
um you know when we say the word men
what we mean
yes yes yes
all right I think that brings us to the
end for today uh we will be back in a
few short days though we will be back in
three days on Saturday July 8th at 12 30
PM Pacific
and uh come back on July and Wednesday
July 9th and from then on we're going to
be doing our live streams at 11 30 a.m
on Pacific on Wednesdays and starting
then we are going to encourage people
who want to participate in a
um in a basically a watch party and do a
chat to to go on to our locals uh for
that and we will have more to say about
that on Saturday
um
let's see other things to mention
Natural Selections this week I just did
a slight review of some of the um some
of the freedoms and rights that we are
we Americans are granted in some of our
founding documents and with high hopes
that uh yesterday marking 204.
we can make it many many more but uh 250
seems like a really good short-term goal
yeah let's make it to 250 and then we'll
talk yeah yeah
um you've got Twitter subscriptions
going although they're
[Music]
anyway uh
sign up and we'll do some stuff uh I
promise and we've got the
darkhorsestore.org where the print shop
and the store run by lovely couple in
Louisville Kentucky and we've got psyop
until proven otherwise and the
somewhat explained saddle up the
direwolves we ride tonight that we
explained that somewhat in the last q a
um
we've got we've got our book Hunter
gathers Guide to the 21st century
available everywhere including signed
copies right here in the San Juan
Islands at darvill's on orcas
and consider joining our patreons we are
going to start encouraging people to go
over to locals and make for instance the
Discord server available there but we
still have we still have stuff going on
at patreon we've got a couple of monthly
conversations that you have we've got a
private q a over at mine and uh and
Discord server is Lively and wonderful
and whenever we do a q a we start with a
question from them
and once again consider checking out our
sponsors this week which were Hillsdale
mud water and Vivo barefoot and
subscribe to the channel like like
episodes that you like share we
appreciate that we are supported by you
and until we see you next time be good
to the ones you love eat good food and
get outside Lilo and avoid the adjuvants
foreign